[Music]
[Music]
hey guys
so in my last video i threw out a few
different ideas for future videos
and quite a few of you seemed interested
in finance so i put together a few notes
and i'll be sharing them
in this video um from a visual
standpoint this is going to be pretty
basic
it's just going to be me talking so
if finance is your thing or you're
interested in seeing a breakdown of the
numbers
definitely stick around either way
thanks so much for being here and
if you're new to the channel and not
subscribed i'm christian shafer i'm an
outdoor adventure photographer
and i've been living on the road full
time for three years first in my suv
and now and my converted ram promaster
okay so the goal of this video is to
share
my monthly expenses of living on the
road versus monthly expenses of living
in an apartment
so you can get an idea of what costs to
expect
and also how much you might potentially
save by living on the road
obviously i can only speak to my own
personal experience so this is not
meant to represent what the average road
lifers expenses might look like
every situation will be different and
one of the great things about road life
is you can easily customize it to
not only fit your lifestyle but also
your budget first things first
living on the road does cost money it is
not free
having a good amount of savings or a
remote form of income is definitely
essential
i'm a freelance photographer so both my
income and my expenses vary wildly from
month to month
um one month i might have four contracts
and the next month i might have none
same goes for expenses one month i might
be investing heavily in camera gear or a
new laptop and the next month might be
relatively low key
so i'm gonna be including my recurring
business related expenses just for the
sake of accuracy but
keep in mind those might not apply to
you i'm going to be going over each
expense item by item
and as we go along i'll be showing a
comparison chart of
how much it costs for suv life versus
van life
versus life in my old apartment also
just in case you guys see me looking
over here
it's because i have my laptop up with
numbers listed just so i don't get those
wrong
um all right so i'm gonna start with
insurance
everybody's favorite and we'll begin
with vehicle insurance
so when i had my suv and i was living
out of my xterra my insurance was 75
a month when i got the van my insurance
was bumped up to
dollars a month um but keep in mind that
ensures the build
ensures the van itself and it also
ensures any of my
non-business related personal property
also that rate is pretty high
so keep in mind that if you have an
older vehicle it's going to be a lot
less than how much mine is
when i lived in my apartment i still had
to have a vehicle and i had my suv so
my insurance my vehicle insurance while
living in the apartment was still 75
a month okay next is camera insurance so
i pay 350
a year to cover my cameras my lenses and
my laptop
and this is the same whether i lived in
my suv my van or my apartment
renters insurance so i just mentioned
that my current rv
vehicle insurance covers my personal
property in the van
well when i was living in my suv and
also the apartment i had to have
renter's insurance to cover my personal
property and that cost 25
a month phone plus internet so i paid 55
a month for my iphone and that's because
i have the apple loan program so that i
can upgrade my phone every time a new
one comes out
and for unlimited talk text and data
with verizon
i pay 80 a month um but that's always
been the same whether i was in my
apartment suv or the van
the only difference is when i was in the
apartment i also had a monthly wi-fi
bill
of forty dollars utilities so this will
largely depend on where you live
and how big your house or apartment is
for me personally
my last apartment was roughly 140 a
month for utilities
in the van everything is solar powered
so i don't have any monthly expenses
there
my main utility expenses are water
laundry and propane when i'm living on
the road for water i usually just fill
up at state campgrounds i have
an annual state parks pass for
washington which is 35
a year and we'll factor that in
otherwise i might fill up at the grocery
store which for 10 gallons of fresh
water is about two dollars and fifty
cents
so we'll round up and say about seven
dollars per month for water
i will throw in another ten dollars per
month for local and campground showers
um i usually just shower at the gym but
and we'll add in that membership fee in
just a little bit
but when there isn't an anytime fitness
location nearby
i might buy like a monthly pass at a
recreation or aquatic center for example
jackson wyoming or moab utah i did that
this past year for both of those places
and there's also the occasional
campground shower that's just more
convenient than
you know driving to the nearest gym when
it comes to emptying my gray water tank
and my toilet i usually just do this at
state park campgrounds as well
sometimes there's a five dollar fee and
other times it's free if you're staying
the night most times i can just find a
gas station or rest stop that has an rv
dump for free
so this is at most ten dollars per month
now that i live in the van
when i lived in the suv i didn't have a
toilet or a gray water tank so there was
no expense there for propane the price
is very minimal um when i was living in
an suv
i would go through those one pound
propane tanks every like two to three
weeks
so at most it was seven dollars per
month we'll say
now that i'm in the van i just got an 11
pound propane tank
and based on the numbers that i've
looked up it's only gonna cost like a
dollar per month based on my usage
and how cheap it is to buy propane by
the gallon on the road laundry costs
about eight dollars every time i do a
full wash and dry so
and i do it every like two weeks so
that's about 16 per month for both the
suv and the van
and in the apartment i had a washer and
dryer so that was wrapped up into the
utility bill
so for the suv 40 a month for the van 44
dollars a month and for the apartment it
was 140
a month for utilities gas okay so this
one was really interesting to work out
um i assumed that my gas bill would be
much higher now
than it was when i was living in my
apartment but
that actually wasn't the case um when i
lived in apartment i would drive crazy
long distances for say a week-long photo
shoot
but then i'd have to turn around and
drive all the way back and when i live
in the van
and when i lived in the suv i tend to
travel really slowly and i
very rarely backtrack so there was a
small difference but not nearly as much
as i expected i've put about 27 000
miles on my van in the past two years
which works out to be about 14 000 miles
per year
um but in my suv the last year i was
living in my apartment
i actually put 14 875 miles on my suv
um so that was higher even and the year
before that
while i was in the apartment i only put
8 000 miles on
but i did live overseas for two months
and i also spent quite a bit of time
traveling by plane
so all of that to say the difference
isn't that big um
if you aren't someone who takes a lot of
road trips already then this might be a
big expense adjustment for you
but if you're someone who already road
trips pretty often then you might be
surprised at
how little this amount changes the
amount of money i spend on gas varies
greatly depending on how much i'm moving
around
but if we take the total amount of money
i spent in 2020 on gas
and divided by 12 i spent an average of
195 dollars per month on gas
if we take the average of two years in
my apartment which would be roughly 11
500 miles um then that would average out
to be a hundred and sixty dollars per
month
and if you're wondering why i know how
much i've spent on gas down to the cent
every year
it's because i have to track those
expenses for my business
i promise i don't do it for kicks it's
because i have to okay
vehicle maintenance this one is a little
tricky because i bought my van brand new
with 100 000 mile warranty
and i haven't had any issues haven't had
to pay for any repairs yet
and oil changes are relatively
inexpensive i paid 155 dollars last year
for oil changes on the van
um i was also really lucky with my
nissan xterra never had any major issues
again i just had to pay for oil changes
which worked out to be about the same
um i did have to get my tires replaced
once which was
about a thousand dollars but that
actually happened when i lived in my
apartment
so i'm just gonna say they're all about
the same they work out to be about 13
per month in my experience obviously as
time goes on that number will definitely
change as my vehicle gets
older and if you're going to buy an
older vehicle
definitely factor in a significant
amount
for vehicle maintenance because you just
things will inevitably need to be
replaced i have friends who have paid
upwards of four thousand dollars
on you know some unexpected transmission
issue
and yeah it's something that you really
want to be prepared for
but that said you know like if you want
to mitigate
those kinds of unexpected repairs to
your vehicle buying a brand new one
is one way to do that and so for me i
lived in my suv
longer than i needed to so that i could
save up money to buy something brand new
food okay so for food i spend anywhere
from 200
to 250 per month this includes groceries
and occasionally eating out
this is basically the same whether i
live in apartment or on the road
because especially in the van i have a
stove i have a fridge and i can cook
in the van the same way i would in a
house that said
i will say food was slightly cheaper
when living in an apartment
simply because i knew where to go i knew
where to get the good deals i wouldn't
see
um you know price increases because i'm
rolling through a tourist town and also
i could
buy in bulk so you might save a little
bit of money there and
on the road i spend a little more time
in coffee shops so we'll say
250 per month for suv and van and 200
per month for the apartment for anyone
out there that thinks 200
a month is low keep in mind that i'm
only feeding one person and i rarely eat
out
also i have a really small fridge so i
rarely if ever waste food
i only buy what i'm gonna eat and if you
don't already know
grocery outlet is like van life mecca
for quality organic foods on the cheap
gym membership so the gym is where i
shower so this is a pretty essential
road life expense for me and i paid 39 a
month for an anytime fitness
membership and they have locations
nationwide and
international and they tend to have them
in cool places like small towns near
national parks and
blm land and stuff like that so it's
really convenient and when i was in the
apartment
um my apartment building had a gym plus
i had a shower
so that's an additional expense that's
pretty unique to just road life
39 a month why did i say that again
next is my storage unit this is not a
necessary expense but
i only pay 26 dollars a month and it was
really helpful to have a storage unit
when i first moved out
because it was less stressful to have to
decide what to keep and what to get rid
of
it's a really small unit it allows me to
keep seasonal gear
and like some heirlooms from my
grandfather so i did not have that
expense when living in an apartment
private mailbox so this is another
expense that applies only to road life
obviously when i lived in my apartment
uh the mail came for free
or you know you pay rent so this runs me
about 17
per month so the next one i want to talk
about are hotels airbnbs and campgrounds
so this one varies greatly um in 2020 i
spent a few thousand dollars to stay
in an airbnb um for two whole months to
quarantine for the pandemic during the
first
lockdown and that was definitely unusual
by comparison in 2019 i spent 187
dollars total for the whole year
um in 2018 i spent 800 so
typically i'm trying to camp for free
like that's why i have the van
it's because i want to get away from
cities and people so
i camp on blm i camp in national forest
so this expense is generally pretty low
i'm not going to count 2020 since it was
a weird year but if we take the average
of 2018 and 2019
i spent about 500 per year on hotels
airbnbs and
campgrounds um to be honest i didn't
save that much by living in an apartment
because when i would go out on a trip
i didn't have everything set up i didn't
have the gym membership to shower
i would bake i would basically just book
a hotel or an airbnb
so the last year i lived in an apartment
i spent four hundred dollars so the
savings was pretty minimal it worked out
to be about 33 dollars per month while
living in an apartment
and 42 dollars per month while living on
the road next up
subscriptions and software this will be
some of the business related stuff that
i wanted to throw in there
um it's across the board the same for
suv
van life um and living in an apartment
costing about a hundred dollars a month
and i'm talking about like adobe
creative cloud
um mobile editing services cloud storage
squarespace website hosting that sort of
thing
business emails but i just wanted to
throw it out there because if you are
thinking about having a remote income
while living on the road those are
expenses that you're probably gonna run
into
parking okay so at my old apartment um
it was an additional hundred dollars per
month for a parking space
on the road i don't pay for parking
hardly at all um i avoid big cities in
general which is where you're normally
going to get charged for parking
um the only time i really have to pay is
if i'm going to get on a plane and go
travel overseas and i need to park my
vehicle long term but i run into those
expenses with my vehicle and a house
anyway unless i'm gonna uber back and
forth
so to be honest i would only say about
five dollars per month
um while living on the road and even
that's like a lot more than
i would normally spend okay taxes so
this is pretty much the same whether you
live in an suv a van or an apartment
i pay federal income tax self-employment
tax
city business tax and also washington
state business and occupation tax
i won't quantify these because i'd
basically be disclosing my
income but i think it's important to
point this out because
living on the road does not mean that
you do not pay taxes
even if it can feel and be difficult to
figure out without a permanent address
it's your responsibility to figure out
how to pay the man
all right rent so obviously this is
going to vary greatly depending on where
you live
how big your place is and whether or not
you have roommates for me
my last apartment cost 2 600 per month
and as for the suv and van i bought them
both outright so
i don't have monthly payments that's
really going to skew
these numbers but it's still pretty
interesting to see
just how much money i have saved by
living on the road
versus if i had stayed in my former
apartment for these past three years
also keep in mind i live for 14 months
in my 2008 suv which you could probably
buy today for like five to six thousand
dollars
you absolutely do not need to spend tens
of thousand dollars on a brand new van
or a build or any of that um an suv
camper setup can actually be really
comfortable and i miss it a lot
sometimes
i miss the 4x4 capability i miss that
you know like i had even less stuff with
me and i could basically camp anywhere
so
just keep that in mind good morning so i
ran out of light the other day so i'm
just gonna pick up where i left off
hopefully i've given you like an
overview of my main expenses
there are a few things that i've left
out but i'll cover those in a minute
and yeah here's where we've ended up so
if i had stayed living in that same
apartment for the last three years
i would have spent roughly one hundred
thirty one thousand four hundred dollars
by contrast my expenses if living in an
suv for the last three years
would be thirty five thousand six
hundred seventy six dollars
and with the van it'd be thirty eight
thousand two hundred thirty two dollars
so by choosing to live in a vehicle for
the past three years
rather than my former apartment i've
saved ninety four thousand
one hundred sixty two dollars even if we
reduce the rent by half
to thirteen hundred dollars a month i
still would have spent roughly eighty
four thousand six hundred dollars
that's a potential forty nine thousand
dollar savings over three years which is
a pretty good amount
um but of course we start to take into
account the cost of the suv
and the van itself so the suv was about
seven thousand dollars
and the van plus the entire conversion
was roughly seventy thousand dollars
with my original rent amount of twenty
six hundred dollars
this ban has already completely paid for
itself and i've saved some money along
the way
even if we cut the written half to
thirteen hundred dollars a month i'd
only be six months out from paying the
entire van off
which is pretty good especially because
right now camper vans are pretty popular
and not only are they pretty much
retaining their resale value but some of
them
are even selling at a profit those are
my baseline numbers i left out
additional expenses like health
insurance
clothes toiletries hobbies that sort of
thing
mostly because those are largely
dependent on you your lifestyle your
personality
and they tend to be the same whether
you're living on the road or in a house
or an apartment although one thing i
will say is since moving on to the road
i tend to spend less money on
stuff in general just because i don't
have space for it so
let's say i'm shopping i see a really
cute jacket rather than be like okay i'm
going to buy this jacket i think wait
do i really want to get rid of something
else i love inside the band just to make
space for this jacket
so as a consequence i end up buying
things that i really only love
or that i absolutely need and whereas
when i was in apartment i would
collect all kinds of stuff that i didn't
really need and ultimately never used
so i would say in general i just spend
less money on stuff with my income and
all other personal expenses thrown into
the mix
i've been able to put away over 150 000
in the three years i've lived on the
road
which is money i can now put toward
buying land and eventually building my
own place to call home
not paying rent or utilities or any of
the other things i've mentioned has
really added up over time
all right so final words let's say
you're interested in pursuing this
lifestyle and you're asking yourself but
can i afford it
first of all it's a really good idea to
have some money put away
this is especially true if you're going
to be hitting the road in an older
vehicle because you just never know what
kind of issues you might run into when
it comes to vehicle maintenance besides
that there's the cost of
food gas oil water propane health
insurance vehicle insurance
vehicle maintenance monthly
subscriptions all the things we touched
on in this video
so you definitely want to have some
money put aside or at least have some
remote income so that you have money
coming in while you're on the road when
i moved into my suv three years ago i
had thirty thousand dollars in the bank
you don't need that much but that's what
i was comfortable with it was enough to
deal with any vehicle maintenance issues
i ran into which by the way
four months after moving into my suv i
totaled it and i did have to
completely replace my vehicle um and you
know it was enough money that
if i didn't like road life i had enough
to put down on first and last month's
rent
and be comfortable for a little while i
tried to figure things out
second lower your overhead so if you
have credit card debt
student loan debt any kind of debt
really i would encourage you to just
look at your expenses
look at your lifestyle see if there's a
way that you can bring those expenses
down and eliminate that debt all
together i have kind of an extreme rule
for myself
when it comes to buying things if i
can't buy it up front i don't buy it
and obviously i've never bought a house
so i'm sure that will be different
but it has worked well for me it serves
as a motivator to work hard toward my
financial goals
just so i can buy things like this van
without
you know the burden of debt following me
around this might mean delaying your
plans to hit the road a little bit
longer while you
say still have a steady paycheck coming
in anything that will allow you to
save up some money to rely on when
you're on the road
um you could look at your expenses and
see where you might cut monthly
subscriptions maybe quit buying lattes
in the morning
cook instead of eating out and also just
buy less in general
and if you are going to buy stuff
consider buying stuff that's high
quality
that's going to last a long time and
that you really love third i suggest you
keep a budget
track your expenses know exactly what's
coming in and what's coming out
and like i said take a look at it and
see how you might adjust to live more
comfortably
or less comfortably if you're trying to
save up money fourth i would suggest
that you consider diversifying your
revenue
streams to include passive income
passive income is the ultimate goal if
you want to live on the road because
it's basically
money that just shows up in your bank
account without you having to actively
work
um and yeah that's something i'm working
toward myself
and youtube ad revenue is a part of that
now so i have you to thank for that so
thank you if you guys found this video
helpful it'd mean a lot if you give it a
thumbs up
and be sure to subscribe to my channel
below
um i put out van life content travel and
photography content
and also i'd love to connect over on
instagram my handle's at christian
shaffer and over there i share
photography work and i also keep you
guys
updated more often on my travel if you
guys are interested in gear
recommendations for hiking
camping photography or van life
essentials
check out the link to my gear page in my
caption below
i get a small kickback every time i use
those links so i really appreciate your
support
and i think that my next video will be
about
an updated van tour so stay tuned for
that and i will see you guys next time